Ja, mir auch.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Frau Schäker.
Ich bin auf der Station als Assistenz-Arztin tätig.
Heute möchte ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nadine Stegemann.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname postabieren?
Nadine schreibt sich.
N-A-D-I-N-E.
Nadine.
Nachname Stegemann.
S-T-E-G-E-M-N-N.
Frau Stegemann oder Herr Stegemann?
Frau Stegemann.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 52.
Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 17. Mai 1971.
Okay.
Wie wiegeln Sie?
66 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Okay.
Frau Stegemann, was für Sie so uns?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 4 Stunden
habe ich ziemlich starke Schmerzen im linken Brustkorb.
Und diese Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, ziemlich plötzlich.
Die waren im Anfang nicht ganz so stark,
aber sie wurden dann im Laufe der nächsten Minuten
dann schlimmer stärker.
Ich ...
Diese Schmerzen beschreiben zum Beispiel
stechend, brennend, dumpfig.
Ja, es mehr stechend der Schmerz.
Mhm.
Schmerzständig.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, die beginnen mehr hinten im Rücken,
so zwischen dem Schulterblatt und der Wirbelsäule
und strahlen dann so nach vorne aus bis vorne zum Brustbein.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen ständig
oder ...
oder kehren Sie wieder zurück?
Also der Schmerz ist immer da, aber er wird schlimmer,
wenn ich tief einatme
oder wenn ich mich so drehe mit dem Oberkörper,
wenn ich den Oberkörper zur Seite drehe,
dann wird es schlimmer.
Das ist ein Problem.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Wenn ich tief einatme,
dann wird der Schmerz stärker,
wenn ich den Oberkörper drehe.
Ach, okay.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöserfaktöre,
vor der Schmessen,
aber Sie gibt mehr?
Ich habe Tennis gespielt.
Ah, okay.
Und ...
das tragt beim Tennis Spielen auf.
Da begann das.
Aber das habe ich vorher noch nie so gehabt.
Mit welchem Hand spielten Sie Tennis?
Ich spiel schon lange Tennis, 30 Jahre.
Nein, ich wollte fragen,
welchem Hand benutzt man Sie?
Ach so, mit welchem Hand ich Tennis spiele?
Ich spiele mit links, mit der linken Hand.
Okay.
Aber es gibt keinen Unfall.
Ist alles in Ordnung in Tennis Spielen?
Unfall gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen?
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal?
Nein, habe ich noch nie so gehabt.
Okay.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Skalafone
ein bisschen bewerten?
Wenn ein kaum Schmerzen und sehr starkes Schmerzen bedeutet?
Dann würde ich sagen fünf.
Und wenn ich tief Luft hole und mich drehe, dann sechs bis sieben.
In Ruhe, okay, fünf,
sieben, sechs, okay.
Und ...
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden neben Dein Schmerz?
Jetzt so seitdem ...
Nee, so habe ich aber Hauptsache, dass dieser Schmerz,
und der macht mir Sorgen eben.
Das, mein Nachbar hat gesagt, du musst ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Das kann auch vom Herz kommen.
Das musst du untersuchen lassen.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt bei Ihnen.
Ja, gut, jetzt scheiden wir.
Und ja, ich möchte noch andere Fragen über Ihre allgemeine Zustand.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Und leiden Sie untermachts-schweiß in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten in den letzten Jahren.
Okay, gut.
Ähm ...
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Also ich habe jetzt Angst, tief einzuatmen,
weil es dann mehr wehtfut.
Deswegen atme ich jetzt immer so etwas flach,
etwas oberflächlich.
Aber normal habe ich keine Atemnot.
Okay.
War Ihnen schwindelig oder wurde Ihnen schwarz vor Augen?
Nein, nein.
Ist Ihnen ein Taubheitsgefühl im Arm aufgefallen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Nee, ist nichts taub.
Kann ich alles bewegen?
Ich kann nur nicht, wenn ich den Arm sich jetzt so hochheben will,
dann schmerzt das hinten auch im Rücken und strahl zu und machen.
Also, damit mache ich jetzt wenig.
Okay.
Ähm, okay.
Ist Ihre Periode regelmäßig oder sind Sie schon in der Menopause?
In der letzten Zeit ist sie unregelmäßig.
Ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorge, zur Frauenärztin und sie sagte,
das kann jetzt sein, dass sie demnächst dann noch unregelmäßiger wird.
Aber ich habe damit keine Probleme.
Mhm.
Unproblem.
Haben Sie Herzrösten?
Jetzt?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Ich möchte jetzt Ihre Vorerkrankungen fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, ich habe seit fünf Jahren ungefähr hohen Blutdruck.
Unternehm ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Ähm, ja.
Was für Medikamente dagegen?
Das Medikament heißt, ich habe das hier auf dem Zettel Rami-Pril.
Mhm.
Und dahinter steht fünf.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Okay.
Aber in letzter Zeit allerdings die Blutdruckwerte nicht mehr zu Hause gemessen.
Da war ich etwas faul.
Früher habe ich die häufiger gemessen,
aber das letzte Mal habe ich die, glaube ich, vor drei Wochen gemessen.
Und da war der Blutdruck, glaube ich, so 140, 135, zu 85.
Leiden Sie an andere chronische Erkrankungen oder nur nur durchdruck?
Also, ich nehme noch ein anderes Medikament ein.
Mhm.
Das heißt, L-Tyroxin 50.
Das muss ich nehmen, seitdem ich, nachdem ich mal
mit der Schilddröse operiert worden bin.
Wieso wurden Sie operiert?
Vor sechs Jahren wurde ich an der Schilddröse operiert.
Die Schilddröse war zu groß und hatte auf der linken Seite zwei Knoten.
Und da hat man gesagt, das muss man operieren.
Aber das war alles gutartig.
Nur ich muss jetzt diese Tablette nehmen,
hat man gesagt, damit die Schilddröse nicht wieder so groß wird.
Noch andere operiert?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Wurden Sie außer Schilddröse operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Und ich hatte einen Leistenbruch auf der linken Seite.
Da wurde ich auch operiert.
One-Milders?
Leistenbruch?
Kann ich nicht mehr genau sagen,
die Blinddarm-Operation war vielleicht mit acht Jahren, neun Jahren.
Und der Leistenbruch mit 12 Jahren.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Also ich war vor einem halben Jahr bei der Hausärztin
zur Gesundheitsuntersuchung.
Und da hat sie den Impfpass angeschaut und hat gesagt,
das ist alles in Ordnung.
Okay, gut, sehr gut.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Allergie oder Unwerte-Regulität?
Also ich vertrage Erdbeeren nicht zu gut und Kiwi.
Wenn ich das esse, dann kriege ich im Mund so ein Brennen im Mund
und Bläschen auf der Schleimhaut.
Und das ist unangenehm.
Und dann esse ich jetzt keine Erdbeeren und keine Kiwi.
Das habe ich aber keine Allergien oder keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Frau Stegerman, brauchen Sie?
Nein, habe noch nie geraucht.
Ja, sehr gut. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, vielleicht einmal bis zweimal in der Woche ein Glas Wein,
aber nicht jeden Tag.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Jetzt möchte ich etwas fragen über Ihre Familienstand
und Familie geschickte Stände.
Leiden Sie Ihre Eltern an bestimmte chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, der Vater, der ist gestorben, da war er 80 Jahre alt.
Im Alter von 80 Jahren ist er gestorben in einem Schlaganfall.
Und die Mutter, die ist sehr leid.
Die ist 86, die hat eine schwere Arthrose an der rechten Hüfte
und auch am rechten Knie.
Da muss sie dann an einem Rollator gehen.
Aber sie wollte sich nie operieren lassen.
Aber sie hat eine schwere Arthrose.
Und dann habe ich noch rechte Knie und rechte Hüfte.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt,
der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und noch ein Schwester, die ist 52 Jahre alt,
die ist 54 Jahre alt, die ist gesund.
Tut mir leid, ich habe ihn nicht gut verstanden.
Haben Sie zwei Schwester?
Einen Bruder und einen Schwester.
Wie alt ist Ihre Schwester?
Die Schwester ist 54 Jahre alt.
Und ist ihr gesund?
Ja.
Bruder Stegerman, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie helflich?
Ich bin Zahntechnikerin.
Ich arbeite in einem Labor, wo Brücken gemacht werden
für die Zähne und Kronen usw.
Sehr gut.
Wollen Sie allein?
Nein, ich wohne mit meinem Partner zusammen.
Tragen Sie Sport außer Tennis?
Manchmal jogge ich, aber nicht so regelmäßig.
Tennis spiele ich zweimal in der Woche.
Spiele ich Tennis und joggen vielleicht einmal in der Woche,
so eine halbe Stunde.
Das ist fast vorbei.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Was kann das sein?
Was können diese Schmerzen sein?
Die machen mir schon etwas Sorgen, weil die auch gar nicht besser werden.
Es ist jetzt so eine Diagnose festzustellen.
Wir werden ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wenn alle Ergebnisse da sind,
können wir eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Ich erkläre Ihnen alle Schritte.
Inklusive der Therapie.
Sind Sie damit so viel?
Ja, bin ich.
Gut.
Danke schön.
Ich wollte gerade der Kollegin sagen,
denken Sie daran, die Angaben der Patienten zu übersetzen
in die medizinischen Fachbegriffe.
Luftartrose, Knieartrose,
Schmerzbanken usw.
Ich habe eine Frage, meine Kollegen.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen oder möchten Sie hinzufügen?
Wer hat die Haut auf der Betroffenen-Stelle?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen auch keine Schmerzen gehabt.
Auf der Haut oder keine Pläne.
Herr Farbunk, wie Hermatom oder Ödem, meine Kollegin,
hat eine Erkostin-Rotung?
Nein, nicht.
Haben Sie Herzlosen? Nein.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bestätigt ein Teilweißgefühl in dem betroffene Bereich? Nein.
Nein.
Bitte schön, Kollegen.
Nach Atemproblemen, ich glaube, wo die schon gefragt haben,
passt irgendwie.
Der Schmerz verstärkt sich bei Einatmung,
bei tiefer Einatmung.
Da tut es verstärkt weh.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Meine Frage ist Frau Stegerman.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Ich habe noch nie geschwollene Beine gehabt.
Danke.
Sie haben aber keine Rötungen oder Bläschen auf dem Haut nicht bemerkt?
Keine Effluoristenzen, keine Rötung, keine Bläschen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie diese Medikamente gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das habe ich regelmäßig eingemacht,
aber nicht regelmäßig den Blutdruck kontrolliert.
Ich nehme meine Medikamente immer regelmäßig.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit ungefähr 4-5 Jahren ist das bekannt.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Beschwäle?
Ja, ich habe eine andere Beschwäle.
Ich habe eine andere Beschwäle,
die ich mit der Bluthochdruck erinnere.
Ich fühle mich sehr schwach.
Ich fühle mich sonst sehr fit.
Als ich heute zum Tennisspiel ging, fühlte ich mich sehr fit.
Das war alles sehr gut und ich fühlte mich sehr gut.
Ich fühle mich sehr fit.
auch alles sehr gut. Bis dann wird diese Schmerzen auftraten.
Danke schön.
Könnten Sie auf den betreffenden Linken an, bewegen, beugen oder stricken?
Auf dem Arm?
Ich habe gesagt, dass Sie Ihre Hand hoch...
Wenn ich den Arm so ein bisschen hochhebe, dann schmerzt das auch hinten im Rücken und im Brustkorb.
Können Sie leichter bewegen?
Weil ich bewegen geht. Ich habe auch Kraft in der Hand.
Kraft, Herr Lust, Sie haben...
Nein, ich habe nicht Kraft, Frau Lust.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Angstgefühlen?
Ich mache mir jetzt Sorgen.
Ich bin jetzt beunruhigt wegen dem Schmerz.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Angstgefühl.
Ich meine, hat die Angstgefühle mit dem Schmerzen begonnen?
Die Angst kam später.
Als mein Nachbar sagte, das kann auch mit dem Herzen zu tun haben.
Geh mal lieber in die Klinik, lasst dich untersuchen.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe mich unruhig geworden.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt, Herr Oberast.
Noch eine?
Ja, ich habe auch einen Sprich.
Also, fühlen Sie sich durch...
Also, fühlen Sie sich durch auf Ihren Brust?
Ein bisschen Druck ist da, aber wenn das so ausstrahlt der Schmerz nach vorne,
beim tiefen Luftbohlen oder beim Umdrehen, dann ist das auch ein gewisses Druckgefühl.
Aber Hauptsache ist dieser Schmerz.
Okay, haben Sie Übelkeit?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Schmerzen Oberbauch?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe noch ein Programm.
Haben Sie früher Lumeninfektion?
Also, ich habe noch nie etwas gehabt an der Lunge.
Ich rauche ja nicht.
Und ich habe noch nie eine Lungenentzündung gehabt oder so etwas.
Ich habe mich fit gefühlt.
Also, ich fühle mich normalerweise jetzt aus sehr gesund, bis auf diesen Schmerz.
Okay, können wir erst als geschiedene Anfang?
Von mir aus gerne.
Die Kollegin ist noch am Vorbereiten.
Ja, fast bereit.
Ja.
Okay, guten Tag Herr Oberrat.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen eine unsere neue Patiente vorstellen.
Haben Sie es seit?
Ja.
Frau Nadine Steigmann ist 52 Jahre alt und 1,68 m groß und 16 kg schwer.
Frau Steigmann kam zu uns wegen seit 4 Stunden pro Gredienter.
Sie haben sich in der Linken Brustbericht mit tief atmen und überkörpernden.
Wenn sie überkörpernden und beim tiefatmen,
sie schlimmen diese Schmerzen.
Vor der Schmerz hat er den Tunis gespielt.
Nach der Tunis spielen, haben diese Schmerzen ziemlich plötzlich begonnen.
Diese Schmerzen strahlen, schinken, rücken und schültern aus.
Und seit 4 Stunden sind immer da.
Ich wiederhole mal, was Sie mir berichtet haben.
Frau Steigmann ist eine 52-Jährige normgewichtige Patientin.
Frau Steigmann berichtet über einen links-torakalen Schmerz,
der wohl er Dorsal begonnen hat und bei tiefer Inspiration und Rotation des Brustkorbes
bis links-Sternal ausstrahlt.
Er strahlt von Dorsal nach links vorne bis zum Stern aus.
Ein torakaler Schmerz, ein torakalschmerz, Dorsal ausstrahlt,
und bei Inspiration verstärkt und bei Rotation.
Gut, machen Sie bitte weiter.
Eine Frage, haben Sie zu Anfang bei der Patientin Vitalwerte kontrolliert?
Wir können jetzt kontrollieren.
Aber ich habe ihn nicht kontrolliert.
Ich würde bei so einer Beschwerdesyntomatik gleich kurz die Anamnese unterbrechen.
Frau Steigmann, ich verbreche jetzt gerade die Befragung.
Ich möchte erst einmal Ihren Blutdruck messen,
Ihren Sauerstoffgehalt im Blut messen und Sie an ein Monitor EKG anschließen.
Das gibt mir mehr Informationen und dann sind Sie auch besser versorgt.
Das beruhe ich die Patientin, das beruhe ich Sie als Ärztin,
weil Sie mehr Informationen haben.
Es war einen sehr guten Eindruck vor der Prüfungskommission,
dass Sie gesagt haben, ich habe erst die Vitalwerte kontrolliert
bei einer Patientin mit einem Torakschmerz.
Okay.
Ja?
Viele Leute denken, das ist ganz wichtig.
Es ist kein Nachteil für Sie.
Gut, fahren Sie bitte fort.
Die Schmerz-Interest-State liegt auf einer Schmeßkale bei 5 in der Ruhe
und sie wohnt bei tief in die Inspiration.
Ja, ich habe 6 bis 7, also 5 in Ruhe
und bei tiefer Inspiration bzw. Rotation zwischen exo 7.
Okay.
Ja, fast praktiziert der Schmerz.
Gut.
Sie benutzt Ihre linken Hand beim Spielen.
Die Beisentone sind unauffällig, aber Sie haben jetzt angesehen,
Angst für tief.
Deshalb habe ich Atomot angesehen.
Ihre Periode ist unregelmäßig, aber sie hat kontrolliert
und es ist unproblematisch.
Seit 5 Jahren leidet sie an arterielle Hypertonie
und dagegen nimmt sie mit 5 mg morgens und abends.
Okay.
Sie messe Ihre Blutdruck nicht regelmäßig.
Seit 3 Wochen messe sie nicht regelmäßig.
Vor 3 Wochen, die letzte Messung erfolgte vor 3 Wochen
und war wohl Normaton, Normaton, also waren wohl normale Blutdruckwerte.
Zumindest nicht sehr erhöht.
Gibt es ein Unfallereignis bei der Patientin?
Nein, sie hat keinen Unfall.
Gut.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Gibt es sonstige chronische Erkrankungen bei der Patientin
oder nimmt diese Patientin andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, sie wurden vor 6 Jahren Triödykthermie operiert.
Sie haben, ich erinnere mich nicht der Fachwörter, aber sie...
Größer heißt Stroma?
Stroma, ja.
Sie hatte Stroma, deshalb wurden sie operiert.
Jetzt nimmt sie 1,50 mg morgens und alles in Ordnung
und sie wurden als Kind Appendectomie und Leistfraktöre operiert.
Leistenbruch, ist keine Fraktur, ein Bruch ist eine Herrnige.
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
Umlikat, Herr Nieg.
Nein, eine nicht.
Ingwünal, Herr Nieg.
Okay.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Der Ingwer-Ei erfolgte eine Appendectomie und eine Herneotomie.
Herr Nieg.
Keine Atomie.
Ingwinal, Herr Nieg.
Herr Neotomie.
Zur Schilddrüße noch einmal.
Die Patientin wurde wegen einer Stroma operiert.
Gab es bei der Stroma noch einen Befund?
Ja, das bekommt mein Stanz chronische Entschuldigung,
chronische Infektion von Pteroidaktomien,
vielleicht Hashimoto.
Es bestand aber bei der Patientin eine Stroma
und im linken Schilddrüsen-Lappen 2 Knoten.
2 Knoten im linken Schilddrüsen-Lappen.
Und dann stellen wir die Diagnose einer Stroma nodosa.
Nodosa.
Nodulus ist der Knoten.
Und dann heißt die Diagnose Stroma nodosa.
Also es erfolgte eine Thyriodectomie wegen Stroma nodosa.
Und die Patientin nimmt zur Stroma profilaxe,
Ältiroxin 50, einmal eine Protap.
Gut, gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie in Anamnese?
Ja.
Ihr Vater ist am Apoplexy mit 80 gestorben.
Ihre Mutter leidet Kokatros und Gonatros.
Kokatros mit X, COX, Kokatros und Gonatros.
Aber sie wurden nicht operiert.
Sie hat zwei Geschwister.
Ihr Bruder leidet an Art.
Unsere Patientin ist Lady.
Sie ist ein Technikerin und hat keine Kinder.
Und wohnt mit ihrer Partner.
Gut, was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja.
Ich bin Musiker.
Aber meine Verdachtdiagnose ist die Repam-Fractur.
Vieler ist es eine Supportverletzung.
Meine Differenzialdiagnose kommen Pynomotorax und Natülle.
Okay, ich sehe hier unten ein Blick, was auf interkostal nur geschrieben ist.
Ich habe hier einen Kollegen.
Erst mal finde ich, warum nicht diese Verdachtdiagnose?
Die Patientin hat Tennis gespielt, hat kein Unfallereignis.
Ist nicht gestürzt, auch nicht beim Tennis spielen.
Aber aus einer Bewegung heraus hat sie diese Schmerzen bekommen.
Manchmal tritt das auf.
Auch im Praxisalltag habe ich das oft erlebt,
dass Patienten mit linkseitigen Brustschmerzen kommen.
Man muss immer daran gedacht werden, ob es etwas Kardiales ist.
Ein linkseitiger Torachschmerz.
Ein akuter Schmerz, der von der Brustwirbelsäule kommt.
Und zwar von einer Blockierung des Gelenkes an der Rippe.
Wir nennen das Kostotransversalgelenk.
Costa ist die Rippe.
Das passiert in der Praxis sehr oft.
Patienten bekommen eine sogenannte Blockierung.
Dann wird der Nerv gereizt.
Wenn ich tief einatme, hebt sich die Rippe an der Torachs an.
Oder wenn ich eine Rotation mache,
reizt das zusätzlich diese Struktur.
Das strahlt aus bis vorne zum Sternum.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Es kann viele andere Diagnosen imitieren.
Diese Dinge gilt es natürlich auszuschließen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
gleich im Anfang, wenn jemand ähnliche Beschwerden klagt,
die Vitalzeichen zu kontrollieren.
Diese Blockierung in der Wirbelsäule ist für die Patientin nicht bedrohlich.
Das ist eine sehr leute, lebensbedrohliche Vital.
Aber wenn wir eventuell ein Coronasyndrom übersehen,
oder zu spät diagnostizieren,
dann kann das schon für die Menschen bedrohlich sein,
lebensbedrohlich sein.
Deswegen ruhig das gleich kontrollieren.
Eine Kollege sagte, interkostale Neuralgie,
das ist so ähnlich wie diese Blockierung.
Wenn man die Patienten nervt,
das ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Diese typischen Verstärker sind eine tiefe Inspiration.
Der Rotationsschmerz, wenn ich mich drehe,
das machen die Patienten dann auch nicht.
Das spricht eher gegen eine kardiale Ursache.
Wenn das die Auslöser sind.
Wenn Sie es untersuchen,
zwei Querfinger,
abseits der Dornfortsätze,
können Sie empfindliche Stellen tasten.
Die Patienten sagen, da tut es weh.
Differentialdiagnostisch, das wurde von den Kollegen
Richtung eines Herbiszoster gefragt.
Muss man auch einen beginnenden Herbiszoster in Betracht ziehen.
Es gibt häufiger eine Herbiszoster,
der gar keine Hauterscheinungen macht.
Die Patienten werden oft leider auf etwas anderes behandelt.
Beim Autopäden habe ich schon erlebt,
der Autopäde behandelt wie ein Brustwirbelsäulen-Syndrom.
Aber es ist letztendlich ein Herbiszoster,
der solche Schmerzen machen kann.
Es war etwas schwierig, aber Sie haben einen schwierigen Fall bekommen.
Aber das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie haben das auch sehr ruhig und systematisch
in der Anamnese erfasst.
Sie haben sich nicht von mir durcheinander bringen lassen.
Das ist ja nicht über uns ganz einfach.
Und es war erfreulich, dass auch viele Kollegen
Fragen gestellt haben.
Das fand ich auch gut, dass die Beteiligung gut war
und die Kommentierung.
Ich könnte die Diagnose kostenlos-transversal
blockiert sagen? Ja, ich würde schreiben Verdacht auf akutes BWS-Syndrom, BWS-Syndrom,
mit Verdacht auf kostetransversal Blockierung oder im Allgemeinen Jagon heißt es Rippengelängs
Blockierung. Und das ist keine seltene Diagnose, das kommt im Alltag sehr häufig vor.
Weite Diagnostik und Therapie, was herrscht? Ja, Sie werden im Blutbild wahrscheinlich nicht
viel Blutbildveränderungen haben, aber ich denke mir wichtiger wäre für mich die Abgleichung,
also das im Blick zu haben, aber wichtiger wäre für mich die kardiale Abklärung, dass sie erst
mal kardial ausschließen, dass sie ein Coronasyndrom ausschließen, EKG, Proponentest, diese üblichen
Sachen, weil das kann für den Patienten ja die größere Negativkonsequenz haben, wenn wir das
übersehen. Alles andere denke ich kann man durch eine klinische Untersuchung machen, indem ich
Abtaste palpiere, den Patienten bewegen lasse und wenn der Patient zum Beispiel sagt bei der
Seitbeugung nach rechts oder bei der Rotation, jetzt ist der Schmerz viel stärker, dann spricht
das nicht unbedingt für eine kardiale Anamnese. Ich habe noch eine Frage, die Patiente hat gesagt,
menstruation Syklis nicht zu gelben, können wir sagen, Pyramine pose der Patiente hat?
Kann man ruhig sagen glaube ich, aber die Kollegin hat ja auch gesagt,
urischer Kontrolle und da ist keine Auffälligkeit, aber es ist wahrscheinlich ein pre-klimakterisches
Geschehen oder re-menopause. Okay, thank you. Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Gut, ja es hat mir viel Spaß gemacht. Ja, es hat mir viel Spaß gemacht. Und die Kollegin hat gute
Fragen gestellt und das gut gemacht und gut übersetzt im Fachsprache immer wieder dran denken,
möglichst nichts vergessen. Die Zahlen nicht verwechseln bei den Angaben wie alt oder wie schwer
und wie groß. Das ist manchmal ärgerlich, wenn das präsentiert wird und bei manchen prüfern ist
das wahrscheinlich sehr wichtig. Für mich wäre es nicht so wichtig, aber es ist so. Gut, ich wünsche Ihnen